اذا في جديد اخبار السودان وفيما يتعلق
بالوضع الانساني شخص من كل ثلاثه سودانيين
كان يعتمد على المساعدات الانسانيه حتى
قبل اندلاع الحرب وبعد شهر على بدء
الاقتتال حذرت الامم المتحده من انها 25
مليون شخص اي اكثر من نصف سكان السودان
بحاجه الى مساعدات انسانيه وللحمايه وقدرت
احتياجات السودان الانسانيه باكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات دولار من ضمنها ما يقارب
470 مليون دولار اضافيه لمساعده نحو مليون
لاجئ فروا من البلاد ليرتفع بذلك حجم
المساعدات المطلوبه من مليار وسبعمائه
وخمسين مليون دولار في ديسمبر الماضي الى
مليارين و600 مليون ستسمح اذا هذه الاموال
لهيئات الاغاثه بالوصول الى 18 مليون شخص
يعدون الاكثر عرضه للخطر داخل البلاد كل
ذلك بحسب مدير مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه في جنيف
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات